this was the moment a passenger plane
careered off the end of a runway
breaking into three pieces the aircraft
stopped just short of a busy road it was
carrying a hundred and seventy seven
passengers from Izmir province to
Istanbul Turkish authorities say the
majority of those on board survived
unfortunately the Pegasus Airlines plane
couldn't hold on to the runway
due to poor weather conditions and
skidded for around 60 meters it fell
from this area from around 40 meters
height 175 passengers two babies for
flight attendants and two pilots were
all 120 passengers were transferred to
nearby this comes just a month after
another Pegasus Airlines plane came off
the runway at the same effort
dozens of emergency workers were at the
scene dousing the flames and evacuating
passengers the plane had had to land in
heavy wind and rain those on board
climbed through large cracks in its side
to escape
most of the passengers have been taken
to hospital for treatment as Turkish
authorities work to establish how
another plane skidded off this busy
runway alle food skew Sky News